so war es gab es bisher noch nie
hologramme zum hören sehen und fühlen
also quasi künstlich erschaffen von
einer sekunde auf die andere objekte ein
britisches forschungsteam hat jetzt eine
neue technik entwickelt die 3d bilder
mit sound und taktile feedback erzeugt
das bedeutet wenn man in solch ein
hologramm hinein greift gibt es ein
kribbeln auf der haut und man stößt auf
widerstand
das ganze wird möglich durch
ultraschallwellen klicks und science
fiction hier gibt's täglich spannende
science videos abonniert den kanal und
aktiviert die glocke nur dann verpasst
er nichts los geht's herzlich willkommen
wenn man diese hologramme durch den raum
schweben sieht muss man einfach an die
star wars filme denken denn auch hier
sind immer mal wieder leute im raum die
schweben sich anfassen lassen und die
sprechen beispielsweise prinzessin leia
im ersten star wars film das ist bisher
pure science-fiction auch wenn sich
heutzutage bereits programme mit
wirklich überraschend guter
tiefenschärfe herstellen lassen
doch diese neue entwicklung eines
britischen forschungsteams top noch
einmal alles wenn zum ersten mal
überhaupt wurde jetzt ein hologramm
entwickelt dass man nicht nur sehen kann
es handelt sich zum beispiel um einen
schmetterling oder ein smiley das auf
knopfdruck plötzlich im raum schwebt
doch nicht nur dass diese 3d figuren
machen außerdem geräusche und man kann
sie sogar spüren
das war bisher noch niemandem gelungen
in der fachsprache ist von taktile
feedback die rede was einfach nur
bedeutet dass man diese projektionen
spüren kann
bereits 2018 hatte das forschungsteam
einfache frei schwebende projektionen
entwickelt wir haben darüber berichtet
dabei verwendeten die fachleute eine
methode mit dem namen multimodal akustik
trap display
hierbei entstehen die hologramme dadurch
dass kleine partikel durch laserstrahlen
angeleuchtet und bewegt werden diese
technik wurde jetzt aber abgewandelt und
statt der laserstrahlen werden
ultraschallwellen eingesetzt eigentlich
ist das ganze gar nicht so schwer
die ultraschallwellen lassen ein
winziges kügelchen in der luft fliegen
und lenken dieses und das disco prinzip
wird genutzt denn geräusche haben enorme
kraft das kann jeder nachvollziehen
der im klub stand einmal vor einer
bassbox getanzt hat das kügelchen ist
quasi zwischen zwei schallwellen die
sich über und unter ihnen befinden
gefangen so befindet sich in der schwebe
und wird
von den fachleuten so schnell gesteuert
dass es überall gleichzeitig zu sein
scheint bis zu 100 mal pro sekunde
ändert der partikel seine position er
rast mit geschwindigkeiten von bis zu
neun metern pro sekunde hin und her
die ultraschallwellen sind für uns nicht
hörbar doch der einsatz von led licht
beschert uns die illusion dass
beispielsweise ein schmetterling durch
den raum fliegen so entsteht also dass
frei schwebende 3d bild das wir sehen in
wahrheit aber handelt es sich aber um
eine einzige kleine plastikkugel mit
einem durchmesser von rund einem
millimeter die sich sehr schnell hin und
her bewegt wo die ideen dazu bekamen das
britische forschungsteam durch eine
bereits vorhandene technik die schon
einige jahre auf dem buckel hat dazu die
rallye an der an der studie beteiligt
war
wir haben uns von alten fernsehern
inspirieren lassen welche einen einzigen
farbigen licht strahlt so schnell über
den bildschirm wandern ließen dass das
gehirn es nur als ein einziges bild war
nahm unser produkt funktioniert genauso
indem er ein farbiges teilchen so
schnell durch den raum jagd dass es mit
dem bloßen auge wie ein
dreidimensionales bild mitten in der
luft erscheint doch zu diesem visuellen
effekt kommt ja auch noch kostbarkeit
und sound auch das wird durch schall
möglich denn auch wenn das menschliche
gehirn nicht in der lage ist ultraschall
wahrzunehmen transportieren die
wellenenergie durch die luft die neue
technik ermöglicht es dem prototypen
diesen dieses zu fokussieren und zu
steuern
die ultraschallwellen werden so
eingestellt dass es zur resonanz
effekten im hologramm kommt dann ist ein
schalt zu hören auch wenn es sich in der
testphase lediglich um einfache töne
handelte
auch der so genannte taktile feedback
wird durch die unter schallwellen
ermöglicht sie werden also auch dafür
eingesetzt dass wir etwas tasten können
wenn sich also eine hand dem hologramm
nähert wird dies durch einen
infrarotsensor erkannt dieser lenkt den
lautsprecher so dass sich der
schalldruck an der fingerspitze
konzentriert dieser schalldruck liegt
bei rund 150 db
das ist ziemlich laut doch er ist für
uns sich hörbar aber dennoch spüren wir
am finger einen leichten kribbeln druck
so hat man das gefühl dass das hologramm
tatsächlich zu spüren ist wichtig
hierbei das direkte greifen des
hologramms das ist natürlich nicht
möglich denn dann gerät das mini
partikel aus der bahn
das neu entwickelte system ist
erstaunlicherweise sehr einfach
aufgebaut die anlage hat die größe einer
mikrowelle und besteht aus 512
13 speichern so viel braucht man sonst
funktioniert es nicht richtig diese sind
so angeordnet dass in ihrer mitte ein
freier raum entsteht dort werden dann
die farbigen und schwebenden hologramme
erzeugt das politische forschungsteam
nutzte lediglich bauteile die es in
jedem baumarkt günstig zu kaufen gibt
also wir können das alle quasi nachbauen
damit erklären die fachleute auch dass
die bislang erzeugten hologramme in
ihrer auflösung noch eher grob sind
bisher ist das eine schöne spielerei
doch die vorstellen wollen diese technik
auch in der forschung sind voll
einsetzen anwendungsmöglichkeiten für
diese technik ließen sich zum beispiel
im labor finden gefährliche chemikalien
könnten mit hilfe dieses prinzips
verrührt werden ohne dass sie durch
berührung verunreinigt werden das
forschungsteam ist jetzt dabei die neu
entwickelte technik zu optimieren
stärkere ultraschall lautsprecher höhere
frequenzen und die weiterentwicklung der
kontrollsoftware sind angedacht so
sollen dann in naher zukunft komplexere
darstellung möglich werden die zudem
auch noch höher aufgelöst sind auch
verbesserte sounds und tast eindrücke
sind das ziel der fachleute hologramm
mit dem smartphone selbermachen geile
technik anklicken anschauen und breaking
up also hier anlegen anschaut und
breaking lab abonnieren ist kostenlos
sie auf youtube lohnt sich auf jeden
fall makula kanal bis dann bleibt dran